[Music]
hey this is the enthusiasm that we bring
to the table yeah um yeah do we have
three up slides on the big screen yes
there we go
just have come welcome hey how's
everyone doing I'm Tim I'm an Australian
uh kind of been floating around in the
scene for a little while I'm super happy
to be here and kind of get the energy
going I'm Jessica I'm an American I'm
not in any scene but I like floating
it's every one of these okay
so CSS cuff is so big it's the biggest
one ever we we kind of found all the big
family photos we're going to take a
family photo at the end of the day but I
just thought would show you the previous
ones and you can just kind of see how
much it's grown and and have what has
become so this is 2013 2014 2015 and you
can see like a lot of familiar faces in
there 2016 we didn't have one
but there was she is a Buddha pet Wow oh
I'm loving the cloud bear tears
compassion Tina oh yes
CSS comes Nordic in as well so 2017
we've got a few new things we have
childcare which is credible yeah we've
got this baby is already more
intelligent than I have and trust me
yeah so we have childcare we have a
quiet room as well sure live captioning
all of the talks are going to be live
captioned in real time yeah I think my
accent is not too bad we can we can get
that through there yeah we also have a
code of conduct of course and the
official kind of statement there is be
excellent to each other if you have any
problem you know reach out to us or any
of the organizers and we'll get that
sorted okay so if you've been to other
CSS comps GS comps before you might
notice we are in a brand new venue this
year arena Hall and oh and this is where
it is in the city this is where you are
right now just what if someone asks you
later
and so this amazing building was built
in nineteen twenty seven twenty eight
and at the time it was the largest like
free span in all of Europe and it was
built to house buses for the transit
company and I thought this was really
cool because the bus was also the
world's largest bus at the time this is
the 1927 store double-decker and so they
would fill this whole space with the
buses and clean them and store all of
the buses here we've come a long way I
feel like it was built in 1927 in
Australia I would not want to be under
the roof but considering its German it's
going to be here forever okay so we have
a ton of good sponsors you can see all
the boobs out there I really advise
checking it out there's really really
good stuff I got a lot going on and we
have a schedule today
it's not just us talking we have some
amazing speakers it looks real lit y'all
and the way it's going to work is
there's going to be two talks then
coffee then three talks then lunch then
three talks and coffees and three
Thaksin party you got it you can go to
the website and check the schedule too
and keep up so at this point in in the
emcee presentations we kind of looked
through the previous ones and there was
Jed and there was Nick and there was a
ton of puns and a lot of CSS puns and
they were really good and I don't know
if you get this thing when you try to do
puns but whenever anybody says one you
like that was really good and I can't
use that now and I just think we're kind
of done there they're all kind of
through
so I kind of wanted to do something
different and we we kind of discussed
back and forth of what we're going to do
and we kind of came up with with
something that we've called the CSS come
party pack hashtag CSS compound crack
trademark patent pending yeah so yeah so
one of the amazing things about this
event about J's comp and this whole week
of events is the community right such an
amazing community there's so much going
on we really like being together with
everyone but maybe you don't have a
community maybe you work remote and you
really want that feeling so I don't know
if anybody has kind of knows me and I've
seen the things that I do I kind of like
to do this thing that I call bad cop'
development where you take a good thing
and you make it bad and you learn from
it and I've been working from home the
last con a couple of years and one thing
that I've kind of missed is
passive-agressive
office notes and this is kind of like
whenever I find a note in my house it's
me that left it to me oh you left the
banana out good one so I kind of wanted
to bring this back into back into my
life so I made a passive-aggressive
office simulator blackpot it's going to
keep everyone kind of going and it's
very intelligent it's very well fed with
real live data
don't forget the organ Amish lunch later
on what's the other no explanation can
go to that this is the third time this
year we've had to buy new folks at the
office please don't take these home
they're for everyone I actually have to
buy folks over a couple of years and it
kind of remembers things as well so
it'll be like whoever left the yogurt in
the fridge please remove it and you're
kind of sitting there and you forget
about it and then a couple of weeks
later we like well it looks like no one
who removed the yogurt classic office
life you can get it today see home accom
office has simulator
all right so not only do we benefit from
excellent German engineering in this
amazing space but we benefit from German
design and things like Bauhaus that are
incorporated today and all kinds of
design and typography and so what could
be a really good way to tribute the
great German laughing everybody here
really appreciates design that's a big
part of CSS and of course I'm kind of
again in this mindset of a bad cop
development so I've created something
called smell vodka and anybody with any
sense is going to start feeling
uncomfortable at the kerning in this
Helvetica you can actually install this
on your machine and this is what it
looks like
or someone else's machine here's tumblr
I can hear some the babies are crying
the children are screaming you can get
it today
see home accomplished smell medica you
can download this it's a really simple
install there's instructions get it on
your friends get it on everyone's
machine mow vet occur is the future all
right and so we also know that CSS has
come a long way and people have done
amazing games and animations created
animation libraries and really great
code pen examples of these silky smooth
animation remember we do that yeah we
have a lot of people that are going to
talk about animations and things like
this as well and it's super exciting and
of course I'm the party pooper
so CSS come party pack I have created
something that I call obnoxious LCSs
rockin sub CSS is the future apart from
snow vatika and it's kind of like a take
on den eating's animated CSS except the
animations are very very very good
obnoxious don't see a sense of noxious
emotions this one's called shake it
that's just way let's just wait it out
plenty of good ones intensifies
really going to get your audience going
trust me fun delicious cool that one got
some hate I didn't even know you could
animate funds until the other day yeah
there's some that might close epileptics
it's so we're going to skip those up
anyway get it today few homes are
complex much it and you can of course
see all of the party packets ehome.com
5c herself party pack get it today